il y à 62 ans la police française
rassemble et 13000 juifs de la région
parisienne c'était la rafle du vel d'hiv
en mémoire des victimes et qui furent
déportés vers les camps d'extermination
par le régime de vichy l'état français
célébrer ce matin ce triste anniversaire
une cérémonie qui intervient alors que
les actes antisémites en france se
multiplient
reportage catherine de manger philibert
landau une cérémonie à la mémoire de
toutes les victimes de la shoah dans un
lieu symbolique
là où en juillet 42 plus de 8000 juifs
furent parqués pendant six jours dans le
vélodrome d'hiver avant d'être déportés
vers les camps de la mort aujourd'hui
alors que les actes antisémites se
multiplient la communauté juive est
inquiète
slam pour le r sch que deux voix tant
d'années après elles mêmes chim mêmes
shing se reproduire cherche est
inacceptable et ça nous n'accepterons
jamais une vacance du pouvoir public la
bande de la justice surtout qu'elle ce
qu'elles se manifestent avec des
jugements plus ferme avec une plus
grande sévérité dans les logements
lorsqu'il s'agit justement de condamner
les actes antisémites qui se déroulera
créèrent des marchands en souvenir des
six millions de juifs exterminés
simone veil insiste sur le devoir de
mémoire
sans cacher elle aussi pour l'inquiéter
demain aujourd'hui ne pas s'inquiéter de
la montée d'un antisémitisme qui ne
s'exprime pas seulement par des mots
mais par de véritables violences
la lutte contre les actes odieux qui
nourrissent l'actualité qu'il s'agisse
de profanation ou d'agressions
antisémites et racistes exige désormais
qu'une veille citoyenne et permanente
vient appuyer ce devoir de mémoire
dans le droit fil du discours de jacques
chirac au chambon sur lignon le ministre
aux anciens combattants appel à la
vigilance civique à la mobilisation de
chacun pour défendre les valeurs de
tolérance et de justice